i'm sweet anita
and i have tourette's syndrome
[Music]
right here okay okay
um how long have you had
tourette's i actually had noticeable
tics before
i was speaking so probably
at least since the age of one or two
weirdly
i would not stop saying michael she's
mecca i have no idea why
but i'd also wolf whistle so i'd quite
often go
and it was so clear and loud that nobody
thought it was me because i was a
toddler
so people thought it was my mom and
they'd think she was hitting on them
so yeah she was like could you stop
doing that because uh
big burly builder men and stuff would
come and hit on her when she didn't want
to and then throughout your childhood
um you were having having these ticks
what was that like as a child
um really confusing and difficult i mean
it wasn't as hard as when i was an adult
because people
expect you to have self-control you say
silly things as a kid and people don't
really
think too much of it but i did swear a
lot and people did raise an eyebrow out
my parents because of it
but uh uh [ __ ] off it was it was pretty
much
not that much of a problem until i got
old enough that people started to be
like
why is this still happening so probably
until i was about 13
it wasn't that big of a deal so did no
one
at that point think that something might
be wrong no
i mean uh i had quite an unconventional
past i was home educated my mom was
disabled and quite often spent
long periods of time in bed and so no
one was really minding me if anything i
was taking care of my mom
and it didn't really leave much scope
for people to notice anything different
about me
we had pre-periods of homelessness and
you know there were times i lived in a
tree house with a bunch of hippies and
they were very open-minded so
even if i behaved in a way that was
different nobody really
questioned it and there wasn't really
that much of a problem until i tried to
go into conventional schooling
so when i started to try real school
i had a lot of barriers i couldn't
explain why i was talking just shouting
over the teachers
i quite often insulted other students
and it kind of all ended with me being
beaten unconscious by a bunch of sixth
formers
when i was about 12 or 13 and i was like
well there's no point
getting an education if you're not going
to have a future to use it in
so i ended up going back into home
education after that so
i'm just going to go into some of the
things you said there and you talked
about um
after a period of homelessness what
happened there my mom was really sick
and she couldn't pay for
oh sorry i think that's probably going
to make a bit of noise
my mom was really sick and we didn't
have much support from the rest of my
family
so uh when she couldn't get out of bed
and she couldn't really function
no one was paying the bills bailiffs
would come over
and i came up with all kinds of tactics
to keep my stuff like
painting my tv with nail varnish to make
it worthless
and things like that and eventually
it just got too much and we had nowhere
to go
i mean i had periods of on and off
of homelessness and it certainly teaches
you a lot about managing the world and
people
um but yeah it was mainly just because
it's pretty much impossible to get a job
when you don't know when you're going to
spank someone or shout something
racist
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much i did used to live
with my
family before me and my mum moved away
and they used to punish me so horribly
for my tics because they thought it was
attention-seeking
so um when i broke my arm i screamed
once
because it was bent in the middle and
they um
my stepmom was like it's not broken
she's just attention seeking she does it
all the time
and they almost didn't take me to the
hospital and when i did go to the
hospital the doctor gave me this little
card from
little smiley faces on it and one of
them was a happy face and on the other
end was a crying face and there was just
like a face in the middle with like a
line in it
and it kind of wear a gradient going
from one side to the other and
he was like point to the face that you
feel because i was little and i looked
at my
my stepmom and she was like dearly first
sort of face and i was like uh
so i pointed to the middle one and they
almost didn't x-ray me
and but they were like just to be safe
she's probably fine
but just to be safe and after the x-ray
they're like yup your kid's a tank um
and yeah i had lots of situations like
that i would go
be sent to bed without any dinner so
many times because i couldn't sit still
and behave at the dinner table
um and i'd do things that just looked
like so bratty
like i'd be eating and i'd be really
enjoying it and then i just smacked them
all across the table
and they'd be like so i ended up in that
situation ha
a lot and it was awkward and scary and i
was embarrassment and i didn't get to go
to put like family things with them i
didn't really know how to explain myself
i didn't know there was a word for what
i was and i had
i eventually had heard of tourette's
syndrome but i had such a stereotype in
my head of what it was that i never
thought
that could apply to me so um it took me
a long time to get diagnosis as well
because
as a kid even i went to i went to
the doctor alone because my mum was so
ill and
um i was like my arm keeps doing this
thing and i'm not asking it to
and sometimes i say stuff i don't mean
to and
the doctor was like do you hear voices i
was like no
do you think you have magical powers no
do you see things that aren't there no
um and so they're like well you you know
you seem
like you've got a perfectly functional
mind you're probably just attention
seeking and you'll grow out of it
and i got told this about three or four
times and it was really frustrating and
i felt really afraid
to engage her with people because i
thought they'd think i was attention
seeking
and i thought that it would
automatically hate me so i was terrified
of interacting with people after that
i want you to look at your lap and i
want you to lift your head up
and look into the lens and stare at it
for about five to ten seconds
okay so put your head down okay and then
i'll cut you in three
two one
so my stereotype of tourette's syndrome
was that it was only swear words that
you always shouted them
and that they were just the same
repeated ones that couldn't ever be in
context
that it could ever be complex and the
things that i was doing when i was alone
were complex sometimes i'd sit there and
i just go i killed 52
000 men and that doesn't seem to fit
with the idea of someone just shouting
one random word over and over
and so because it seemed so complex and
sometimes even situational
sometimes even a punch line i'd never
have the wit to come up with myself
i thought it couldn't be tourette's um
but that's all completely wrong and even
though my kind of tourette's is very
rare
um it's definitely a stereotype of
turrets if by
by a medical standard if not by a
societal standard
it can be incredibly lonely and
stagnating i felt like i had no future
i had no idea where i was going to go
what i was going to be i
didn't feel like i had any control over
my life
and it didn't seem like that was ever
going to change i was incredibly
depressed i ended up depressed for 13
years
i was not only socially phobic but also
socially inept i was really awkward and
terrified of people um never liked to
even make eye contact that was
terrifying
and while we were back talking about
that kind of difficult time
i notice you've got some i don't know if
you don't the hat obviously if you want
to know if you've got some scars on your
arm there
was that something that was during your
this the period of depression you were
going through
so i started self-harming as a way to
cope with
everything that i was going through and
it was a lot it wasn't just
it wasn't just tourette's syndrome it
was intermittent homelessness
it was my family punishing me for ticks
it was you know all sorts of things but
that all started when i was about eight
or nine
and i didn't think that anyone would
ever know that i did it
um and i don't mind talking about it
because i'm not ashamed
though that was me not finding the best
coping mechanism but still coping
and i managed to cope with a lot more
than most people can cope with
and that is just evidence that i can
handle it and that i got through it and
survived it
in the end i found healthier ways of
coping but nobody shows you that when
you're nine
so this was what i did and yeah luckily
don't do it anymore it took quite a few
years to get over it and figure out
better ways
but yeah like i said i'm not ashamed
that i got through it
were your family worried about you at
that point i didn't really interact with
most of my family
it was just me and my mom and my mom had
plenty going on
she was pretty distracted at the time so
it was
just me dealing with it the funny thing
about
dealing with anger alone as a child is
that if you learn
that no matter how much you smash no
matter how much you rage or scream
no one cares and no one's coming you
start to bury the rage and detach from
it
and that can be really weird because
if you disengage from your anger and you
don't address it
you lose or hope that things can change
because
anger's a hopeful emotion it's when you
don't stand for how things are
and you want them to be better and if
you lose that
it can be very defeating and it can be
very depressing
in my early 20s i've had enough this is
definitely involuntary this is
definitely not attention seeking i do it
when i'm alone
i know it's not about other people and i
went to the hospital and i was like i
really need this diagnosed i want a life
uh
and uh they did some tests they
gathered my pee for an entire week i had
to pee in the same jar
for a week and i didn't have anywhere to
live at the time so i was sleeping on
someone's couch and i was like that's
not apple juice don't touch it
and uh yeah uh that's how i got
diagnosed finally
but they diagnosed me initially and
didn't get around to telling me for five
years so i ended up being about 27
when i finally got the piece of paper
that says you have tourette's syndrome
and my life started
and i got a job i got an explanation
and i got friends and everything started
for me because the minute an involuntary
and offensive action has an explanation
people can connect with you and relate
to you
[Music]
and then well so once you've got the
diagram and what you know you know
you've got tourette's
what um what did it change in your life
what's the main thing it changed
i shed so much guilt so much guilt
it was devastating to see that i kept
hating people's feelings
and people kept pushing me away and
ah people kept people get
kept judging me and i kept hurting the
people around me that i really cared
about even my mama used to pinch on the
back of the arm as a tick it got me
kicked off a bus once because i did it
to a stranger
and then whilst that person got up to
tell the bus driver
i did it to another person so i got
kicked off and i was spent i spent like
god knows how long it was hours and
hours and hours and hours trying to find
my way back home i think that happened
when i was like 13.
so yeah uh after i got my diagnosis
it felt like it wasn't my fault and
there was no amount of therapy
and there was no amount of like
restraint and there was no amount of
anything that could have prevented that
from happening and it wasn't because of
me and it wasn't because i was a
terrible person
which was really freeing like i felt
like i'd been carrying all this guilt
because i just didn't know how to make
it stop
being able to explain what's going on
helps you to connect with people who
might otherwise
write you off as crazy or think that you
hate them
and because some of my tics are violent
it's so important
to me for people to understand that
that's not intentional
at first i was just i used to gather sea
glass to de-stress
and i sold that online so i didn't have
to interact with people
i saved that up and used the money from
that to buy craft supplies and i was
selling craft supplies when i was
you know i rented a couple of offices i
started to build on that and it started
to grow and i felt really great
but then i tried streaming for the first
time i used to play a game called
overwatch online on the pc
and the reason why i did that was
because i discovered push to talk you
hold down the button you speak you lift
up no one can hear you oh my god for the
first time people knew me
before they knew i had tourette's i got
talking to this guy and he's got i've
got com
he said i've got a confession to make
i'm streaming and i was like i don't
even know what that is i don't care
um so he dropped me a link and his chat
was like this is a voice actor a
streamer or a sound board
that that is what this person is and the
reason why is because i can imitate
a lot of things that i hear i have
echolalia it means that if i hear a
sound
sometimes it triggers a tick and it's to
play back that exact sound
it means that i can imitate a lot of the
game characters because they say the
same thing over and over again and it
triggers me
and so because i was able to mimic them
they thought voice actor soundboard
or streamer one of the three gotta be
and they were hunting for me but i
wasn't there i didn't have an online
presence
belle even had a facebook back then and
so
yeah i thought if i could be these
things without even trying maybe i
should give it a go
and now i've been all three um and the
thing with that
is is i if i hadn't bumped into that
into that specific dude i probably never
would have gotten started
um and it was completely unintentional i
didn't know enough about streaming for
me to have any expectations that it
would go anywhere
i thought a big streamer was someone
with a hundred viewers and
i think the most i've ever had looking
at me at once is about
oh about 30 000. so
yeah um big big skip from
what i expected to what actually
happened yes it's live and lots of
people are very angry that it's live
they're like you can't help what you say
you say things that are very hurtful
um what if people don't want to hear
these hurtful things how could you force
that on them go on a delay
and so i kind of felt like no i'm just
gonna
do what i want and act like i'm everyone
else equal to everyone else and have
every right to interact with people the
same way everyone else does
until twitch bans me which is what i
expected to happen
i have the n-word tick unfortunately
that is a no-no
i put in the title of pretty much
everything i create online that i have
tourette syndrome
no one's hearing any of this against
their will they are warned
and the thing with that is as well not
only are they warned
but context matters so if
swear words in and of themselves are so
terrible that nobody should ever have to
hear them
and anything that contains them should
be banned we have to ban the dictionary
and wikipedia context matters it's so
obvious and because i'm not trying to
denigrate anyone
or hurt anyone the reason i've been let
off is to allow access for people with
disabilities
that doesn't mean that twitch is also
going to allow racism
so yes context matters and that's why
i'm still here and i'm really glad
that the platform has the clarity to
recognize that and let me be a part of
all this
there's a a lot more acceptance than i
expected
and that the internet isn't this cess
bit that everyone
makes out to be there's a lot of really
lovely people out there really eager to
support and
help each other and yeah i'm really glad
i found that out
when you look at um when you think back
to 15
10 18 year old teenage anita
and then you think about the fact that
you said you've seen like 30 000 people
mm-hmm twitch how does that make you
feel about it
i don't know i would have never expected
it i'd have never thought it was
possible
uh this is not where i expected to be
we're going to get some shots of your
hands now
i'm just going to and if you just focus
on it just keep them there and i can see
where you're kind of slightly pulsing
your hands there
we're going to get some shots of your
hands pulsing because we get at the cut
away too essentially so if you just
move your hands a little bit i'm trying
not to think about it now
um okay and then so what there's
the most common ticks you have oh for me
uh mostly winking and whistling
unfortunately
uh it's fine in public because most
people tend to ignore it in clubs
it's another story um the amount of
people who've got chatting to me and
bought me drinks and i've been like wow
people are so nice here and they've gone
don't take this wrong way but do you
have tourette's
yeah they're like oh and you see like
the realization
that she's not into she wasn't beckoning
me over i'm
dumb um but yeah apart from that it's
mostly okay for those two i flip i flip
off a lot of people and i've raised my
middle finger to pretty much everyone
babies adults old people drivers ah
the worst one is it's mostly triggered
by people letting me cross the road
if some cast pulls over and lets me
cross the road
i do this at them and
i also make wanking gestures
unfortunately as if i'm a dude
there are actually clips of me doing it
um on pornhub
and they've gotten so many views and
it's not me who's put them there
some random dude has clipped me making
that gesture
um and put it on pornhub and it's
actually gotten more views than
some of my youtube videos there should
be a word for tourette's fetish because
it's definitely a thing
and it's creepy it's not cool like when
people i find them really sexy
it's like i'm finding an exit now like
it's it's it's i i've never had trouble
attracting people
and i even get propositioned in the
street after people have watched me for
a while
shouting at cans of tomatoes and things
and so for some reason or another it
doesn't repel people as much as i'd like
um and i like both men and women
so i have had relationships with both
and it's never had
any kind of deterrent effect on either
i've had stalkers ever since i was
young um uh like that's happened to me
every now and again
some people just get a bit too friendly
you know and don't let it go but
since i've been streaming i had i've had
a few people stalk me and trying to
figure out where i live
and things like that and not really been
very successful um
one guy in particular found out where i
lived
and started camping in my back garden
started following me in the streets um
he assaulted me and i reported at the
police and they did nothing
and he would spend hours knocking on my
door
um he would fall asleep in my front
garden he'd
watch my house day and night he'd stand
out there in the rain
watching my house waiting for me to come
outside
when the police went to detain him when
i reported him one time
they found him on the way to my house
with a knife and
he made constant threats while i was
streaming that he was
going to kill me on stream that he was
going to be there in five minutes and do
it for everyone to see and
it took a long time for the police to do
very very little
and i felt like i was completely on my
own no matter how much footage i took no
matter how much i submitted the
messages and the threats and the hate
and the harassment
and it went on for
so long before the police ever even gave
him a restraining order
what has tourettes taught you about
yourself um breakfast
i'm a breakfast cereal um
i don't know i genuinely don't know uh
it's frustrating because my tics tend to
be smarter than me they're capable quite
a lot of things that i'm not
um they have great delivery on one
liners and jokes that i just don't have
and couldn't match up to and sometimes
it takes me
a couple of seconds to figure out the
joke and laugh at it with everyone else
so yeah um
i guess it my tics have a better sense
of humor than me and faster reflexes
than me
um i can react to things as a tick much
faster than i would have
intentionally and then do you have
methods to control your texts
i whistle a lot back that annoying biker
passed by
there we go okay do you have any ways
any like
kind of ways you've got to control your
tics uh yeah
i whistle so it helps me in the bathroom
a lot because
a difference between whistling a tune
which people don't seem to mind or even
mention um or shouting i can hear you
[ __ ]
so yes uh whistling has saved me in a
lot of situations you're suddenly
walking behind a bunch of school kids
and yeah
it gives me a lot of control what do you
whistle what do you miss or a particular
tune or
just oh i can whistle anything anything
that gets stuck in my head really i
whistle a lot of game songs because i'm
a gamer but i whistle all sorts of tunes
studio ghibli tunes and classical and
just
anything um bobby ferran and just
yeah anything and uh it's
so much better than offending people
waiting for trains people
like i put my coffee cup down for a
second
and whistled while i checked my phone
and i looked up and there was money in
the coffee cup because i was whistling
i love echoey places because it makes
whistling sound amazing
um so yeah that that that's how i cope
and i do it a lot i don't really stop
most of my day is whistling without much
practice you must be amazing at whistler
i guess that's subjective you said
um i'll kill you tourette's um
means you burn more calories oh yeah
definitely burn more calories uh
i have like a little chicken wing goes
up and down like all the time and
like you expend a lot of mental energy
um so tourette's a lot of people don't
know
i have mental tics as well as
verbal tics so you're not hearing all of
my texts
sometimes uh it's if you could imagine
trying to remember a phone number or
doing complicated math for someone
shouting loads of random
like numbers at you that is what it's
like i
it's really hard to focus it's really
hard to maintain a certain train of
thought
and so you expend a lot of mental energy
just trying to focus on
anything but also you get kind of ah
you get you get a lot more movement in
your day-to-day
um so your body's doing all sorts of
things um
just aside from what you'd actively
choose to do and so
yeah there are days where i eat a lot of
food uh a lot a lot and i didn't realize
how many extra calories i was eating
until i started tracking it
so i eat uh yeah sometimes between three
thousand and six thousand calories in a
day not every day
some days are fine but yeah that can be
the case
that must be incredibly frustrating for
something
i was never angry with myself i noticed
very early on that the more frustrated i
was with it or the more i anticipated it
and worried about it the more often it
happened and the more likely it would be
the most self-sabotaging kind of tick
the thing is if you worry about doing
something
it's very likely to become a tick and
start happening more often
she's got me in a lot of hot water
actually can you give us an example of
the hot water you're going to see
yeah i've um oh i have so many examples
it's unreal i've
thrown orange juice across the shop and
smashed it on the wall i've
um shouted racial slurs in a toilet
cubicle and come out and been surrounded
by
black women and been like oh oh no um
you know i've
shouted and stuck my middle finger up at
so many people especially drivers i
nearly caused a car crash in a taxi
because
i shouted cats cats is one of my longest
ticks i had it ever since i was little
um it started as caterpillar and then
for some reason got abbreviated to cats
along the way
and unfortunately if you show a cat when
someone's driving they slam the brakes
and so we almost had an accident and now
whenever i get in a taxi
i end up having to say hi
i have tourette's syndrome if i shout
cats don't slam the brakes if i offer
your fisting
don't try to take me up on the offer and
usually
people take that really well and it's a
conversation star whereas if i say
nothing
then bad things can end up happening
because of the misunderstanding there
were certain situations where it didn't
happen
and i didn't know why when i interact
with animals when i'm caring for someone
i don't take as much when i whistle i
don't tick at all
and when i you know when i focus and
fixate on something without distraction
the ticks go away it gives me a lot of
control a lot of people with turret
syndrome they can make
music or they can do something that
really engages them mentally i have a
friend
who has tourette's he punches himself in
the face a lot unfortunately
put camera in his hand and he's fine and
you wouldn't know he has
any ticks at all um so he does
photography
to help him and it's become his job the
thing is
weirdly if something becomes a respite
from having the condition
you tend to do it a lot and that means
that we often end up with unexpected
talents
and most of them are creative you'll
find a lot of singers and artists with
tourette's syndrome
because it tends to engage the mind in
just the right way
weirdly um maybe i shouldn't bring this
up but i'm good anyway
sex is one of those things um and
a lot of people who have tourette's tend
to report that they have fewer ticks or
none during sex
but the thing about that is that's
because it engages your focus
so that only applies to good sex which
is really
brutal because i've never heard a guy's
ego more than simply going
during an intimate moment um and i have
had tics
like i i punched a dude in the dick
um and then
do you know pre when you you said you
entered a taxi you pre-warned
the the taxi driver are there any other
places where you pre-worn
um
customer service if i can doesn't always
work
um with customer service if i go to a
foreign call center not a lot of other
people
in other countries are very aware of
tourette syndrome and they
think they don't care until it starts
happening and then they don't understand
anyway um so yeah
the customer service taxis what else
just anywhere where i have to speak to
anyone for a long period of time really
[Music]
not being neurotypical gives you a
different perspective it's
really good for evolution to have lots
of different kinds of brain
and neurodensity like lots of
interconnected areas of the brain um
cause things like autism
tourette's syndrome ocd and what's the
other one adhd
these are kind of non-neurotypical
people and
you can find a lot of talent in them not
just creatively for people with tourette
syndrome but things like having
impeccable memory as someone with autism
this isn't a disadvantage or a
disability it's just a different
perspective
and it's given me a lot of advantages as
well so i don't
see it as a flaw to correct i see it as
an opportunity to contribute from a
different avenue than everyone else
so i'm not trying to fix myself i'm not
crying over the fact that there's no
cure i'm not looking for a cure i'm not
trying to work against myself
i kind of see myself as a triangle in a
world full of circle slots and everyone
thinks i'm going to try and fit through
them like everybody else does
but if i trim off my corners i don't
become a circle
i'm less than a circle so i'm going to
use my edges the best that i can
[Music]
i think i've got a little way more to go
before i'll be proud
but i'm pretty content and that's enough
is there anything that you
want to say that we have in coverage
[ __ ] off
nope can't think of anything
[Music]
scuffed
[Music]
what's that
sure what you want to hear uh let's see
[Music]
wow
[Applause]